EVERY GAME THIS YEAR.
HE DOES  WITH THE
EQUALLY HOT CALGARY FLAMES AND
CAROLINA HURRICANES. E  FORMER
TOOK IT AWAY, BRACING AGAINST
THE
OF THE NIGHT.
>> Randy: LET'S GO BACK TO THAT
FOURTH LINE.
THEY ARE DOING SOME DIRTY EY SC
LONG HOME RUN PASS BACK THE
OTHER WAY.
ON THE BREAK AWFOR PHILADELPHIA
IF IT GETS IT CLEAR
IT LOOKS LIKE IT IS GOING TO BE
ON THE PANTHERS.
A DELAYED CALL.
KONECNYB .
WAITING.
FLYERS HAVE AN EXTRA SKATER ON
THE ICE. GLOVED
DOWN, PLAYED DOWN THE
CLAUDEB GIROUX. THE FLYERS CHAN
THE POWER PLAY.
IT WAS A
LOMBERG TRIED TO SPEED BY, THE
CHANCE, THEY SHOT OFF ,   THINK
JONES.
HEY: THIS IS WHAT THIS 20-
YEAR-OLD SUPER KID CAN DO.
LOOK AT THON GETS IN AND SERGEI
BOBROVSKY STANDING TALL RIGHT
THERE.
NICE.
TRIPLE L .  THE FLYERS ON THE
HIS STICK, HERE COMES
COUTURIER. SCORES.
SAM BENNETT FROM DUCLAIR AND WE
ARE TIED AT 1-1 ,  TIMED PERFEC
BENNETT.
AARON EKBLAD START IT OFF.
TIPPETT WITH LOST
CONTROL OF THE PARKING AND IN
THE FLORIDA ZONE, THE TURNOVER.
THERE IS THE STARTING BLOCK.
LOOK AT THE PANTHERS COME
VERHAEGHE, 20 GET THE LEGS
COMING  ZONE.
ALONG THE BOARDS.
BENNETT, ALONE IN FRONT, SAVED
BY JONES.
WHAT A CHANCE GETS TO THE FRONT
THE NET.
THE BACKHANDER CAME THROUGH THE
SLOT. LONG SHIFT
TRYING TO WORK IT FREE.
JOE F. B GIROUX  PUCK, IT
DEFLECTS OFF THTHPANTHERS. OT
BLOCKED AWAY.
KONECNYB  STOLEN AWAY BY
BE.THE LINE, MAKES A MOVE
IN CIRCLES WITH IT.
AARON EKBLAD IS BACK ON THE
ICE, IT AGAIN.
THAT IS